clear on the south
all right hold the perimeter everyone
else on me eyes sharp
nice and easy we don't want to spook the
neighbors
hey guys pete here the end of better
call saul is officially underway and i'm
here to discuss the latest chapter in
what's shaping up to be a fantastic
final season point and shoot once again
drove home the idea that actions have
consequences and it tied up a lot so
that they can get around to answering
the big questions jimmy and kim just
need to keep telling the lie they've
been telling easy enough right i guess
we'll see i'm taking off my tie but
leaving the collar button just in case
and i'll be getting into everything that
happened right after i warn you that
this video will contain spoilers for
episode 8 a better call saul's sixth
season and with that out of the way
let's get into it
we do pick up right where the last
episode ended like candles still exactly
the same size fresh blood still
streaming down the wall and mid freakout
watching howard's blood pool at our feet
right where we left off we don't get
there until after we have an ominous
teaser that starts off as a beautiful
shot of a beach that slowly reveals that
it's anything but by the time you see
the namaste plate it's probably already
come together that this is a flash
forward showing what the cover story of
howard's disappearance looks like lalo
has a plan and he's going to need jimmy
and kim to focus so he can explain it
what i love about this plan is that when
you first hear it it sounds a little
flimsy why would lolo leave the crucial
part of his plan against his arch enemy
up to these two inexperienced cowering
civilians the answer doesn't come until
later but it's so satisfying when you
finally put it together what he tells
them is he wants jimmy to get in his car
and drive over to someone's house and
shoot them there's a reliable idiot
proof revolver in the glove box and all
they have to do is point and shoot it'll
be no problem at all because this guy is
a house cat he almost looks like a
librarian but don't be fooled because
even a house cat can scratch with the
hard part out of the way just take out
the camera and do the exact same thing
point and shoot and what initially seems
like a puzzling turn
jimmy tells lalo that he needs to send
kim and i suppose this is as good a
place as any to point out the incredible
performances these actors deliver bob
odenkirk sells that he's stunned while
he shifts into survival mode ray seahorn
had me sort of sympathy shaking along
while her character is absorbing the
reality of the situation and tony dalton
delivers one more example of the
adaptability that exists right next to
his menacing core for my money the
brilliance of this scene is in jimmy's
decision of course no one watching was
thinking they should send kim it even
takes annoying lalo to the point where
he just agrees to shut them up if jimmy
were to go he would have to do exactly
what lalo wanted because kim's life
would be at stake by sending her he's at
least opening up possibilities and i
think this hits home when he looks her
in the eyes and tells her that she has
to go i believe at that moment jimmy has
to accept that this might be the last
time he ever sees her that he might be
sacrificing himself so she has a chance
to live and wow bravo gordon smith talk
about putting a character in a situation
where they have to make a tough but
ultimately correct decision after being
reminded that she'll need her shoes kim
does follow the plan like a person who
is trapped inside a nightmare that they
can't wake up from there's a great shot
where she's sitting at a light and a
police car pulls up next to her with its
window rolled down which presents her
with an out because she doesn't take it
it proves her dedication to doing what
she has to do to get back to her husband
who we now know has been tied up and
left behind as lalo puts the next step
of his plan in motion
sending someone to gus's house was only
part of what he had in mind i'm sure
he'd be happy if they were able to kill
him but ultimately it doesn't matter
what he's counting on is a diversion
that would pull his guys away from the
super lab and from there things play out
like you'd think they would if you've
been paying attention kim is intercepted
at the door and pulled into the house by
mike he learns that lalo sent her and is
at their apartment right now that has
him pull tyrus from the laundry and send
him there and that presents the
opportunity for lalo who's waiting out
front to get inside and find the lab gus
decides to call and ask him some
questions and the idea that they were
able to talk lalo out of sending jimmy
sets off an internal alarm that doesn't
sound like the lalo he knows and he
starts to realize that this is all just
a diversion from there he heads to the
lab and the showdown is on i've been
convinced that lala would have to die
before better call saul came to an end
and that left me wondering how they
could make that seem satisfying
especially as it started to seem more
and more likely that it would happen
with the gun at the lab the answer to
that comes in the most obvious way you
just put these two amazing characters in
a room together and let them taunt each
other from lala's perspective he has the
upper hand and will finally get what he
came for he relishes the impending
victory by talking into a camera for don
oladio's benefit but the chicken man has
his backup plan ready to go and he has
his own words for their boss before he
springs into action this somewhat brief
exchange brings back so much of the
character's histories from the moment he
was introduced in the series everything
he's done has brought lalo to this place
with the sole purpose of taking down
fring gus has been playing the long game
of exacting his revenge and he even gets
to explain it out loud to lalo before he
turns the tables and i would give him
extra points for calling eladio a greasy
bloated pimp we had seen him set the
stage back in episode 5. he can cut the
lights with the extension cord and knows
exactly where his idiot-proof revolver
is hiding in the dark he turns out to be
the one to point and shoot and not stop
until it's empty and he is able to hit
his target the obvious problem with
killing off a character like this is
that you don't get any more tony dalton
but since he did have to go i think they
did the character justice gus is able to
pull himself together enough to stand
over him to witness his last moments and
watches as eduardo lalo salamanca dies
laughing the episode doesn't end there
though remember i mentioned consequences
at the beginning and they set those up
before we cut away i thought it was a
great choice to start this off with lyle
who's the kind of guy who goes in early
to open singing the jingle of the place
where he works he learns that he's gonna
have to open and close two days in a row
gus tells him that it's because he was
called out of town but it's really
because he took a couple of bullets in
that shootout jimmy and kim are reunited
when mike brings her home neither are
unaffected by what they just went
through but they are both safe for the
time being mike and his guys will take
care of cleaning up howard's body but
they're gonna have to jump right back
into their lives as if nothing happened
and you can see that this is something
both characters would understand
intellectually that it's necessary but
as viewers we know that this is easier
said than done they may have the
sandpiper settlement coming in but how
do they go back to enjoying their
takeout in the same room where they saw
howard bleed out back at the lab they
dig a grave to bury these two characters
together you can see that mike has
feelings about howard ending up there
because he was definitely not in the
game as he removes his wallet wedding
ring and shoes to tie back into the cold
open ending the episode by burying them
together is certainly a way to answer
the question of how the cartel and
lawyer sides of the story would
eventually come together now when you
watch breaking bad it'll be hard not to
think of them when you see the super lab
lalo certainly got what was coming to
him but at least he got a payoff for all
this time looking into gus he got
confirmation that he was right about his
suspicions and as i alluded to earlier
gus does put him in his place he even
spells it out for him essentially saying
look i'm smarter than all of you guys
that's why i'm doing this you're all
terrible you're just like jackals and
you can almost imagine lalo having a
respect for this person who is taking
him down on the other hand howard just
played the game and lost and what's
worse is that he'll be remembered as a
drug addict that killed himself thanks
to these two worlds colliding it's a
dark way to end things for him and it
makes you wonder how bad things might
get for the ones who managed to make it
out alive because the idea of kim dying
is not one that i've ever thought was
gonna happen but it really looks like
it's not gonna happen after this at the
end of the day there are a lot of things
that are working out exactly as they
were planned but then something else
comes along and well then that happens
too it's all about the aftermath now and
what comes next and with five episodes
to go it's kind of exciting to not know
for sure what will happen
i don't think this episode was quite as
good as the previous one but it did do a
fantastic job of wrapping up the
inevitable parts of the story it's a
little bit surprising that they killed
lalo off with so many episodes left but
just as was the case with nacho it makes
perfect sense now that i've seen it with
the big question of how lolo dies out of
the way we can focus on what happens
between jimmy and kim and there's still
half of a regular season left for them
to get into that we watch them both
reinforce their dedication to each other
in this episode and that makes it a
little harder to see where their split
happens jimmy made the choice to
sacrifice himself by sending kim and i
imagine part of him was hoping that she
would just keep going i doubt he thought
she would ever pull the trigger i
certainly didn't think she would even as
she was ringing the doorbell i suppose
the question is whether she thought she
would do it and i don't think they make
that clear what you see is someone who
knows she has an hour to get back to her
husband taking each step as it's
presented to her right after she left i
was thinking about how would she react
to this decision that jimmy's sending
her out to do this dirty work but by the
end i think it's clear that she's worked
that out in her head that it was the
right decision either way we never saw
her falter and the hug when they're
reunited is almost unnecessary to show
how they feel about each other the real
problem is what living with this
situation will do to them i thought
jimmy catching that glimpse of them
putting howard's body in the
refrigerator was a nice way to emphasize
this sort of like hey look it's not all
bad at least you got a new refrigerator
out of the deal it reinforces this idea
i've had that the saw routine in
breaking bad is just a coping response
from all this stuff that he's going
through and that means the big question
is how will kim handle it this was
gordon smith's final writing credit for
the season it was another great job to
follow up rockin hard place kind of
interesting that he crafted fitting
endings for both of the characters that
came about from saul's line in the
desert i think since the big events were
mostly expected where the writing excels
here is in the details even though it
was super dark they managed to slip in
some funny moments to keep things a
little lighter i liked seeing lalo put
the gag on jimmy as he was saying it
wasn't me it was ignacio as a wink and a
nod to the fact that we've been
discussing that line forever and i don't
know why exactly but i thought it was
hilarious when kim pointed to the fake
gus in that scene there were a lot of
great references and a lot of shots that
mirrored things we'd seen before off the
top of my head jimmy tied up looking at
howard reminding me of walter and
ozymandias mike coming in to clean up
jimmy and kim's apartment reminded me of
his first appearance at jane's apartment
lalo meeting his end through the object
of his revenge reminded me of hector and
gus's next face-off and there are just
too many more to name but the good news
is we'll be bringing the live stream
back again tomorrow so i'm sure we'll be
discussing some of that when we're
talking there since vince gilligan
directed this episode i don't have to
point out that it was visually stunning
but i wanted to take a second to
appreciate the use of the teaser this is
something that has become so common that
it's almost hard to remember how much
these added to the experience of
watching breaking bad for the first time
this one reminded me of that and all of
the great ones that came before it
starting off with this beautiful shot
that catches your attention and then
watching it shift to becoming a lot more
unsettling it's something that a lot of
other shows have tried to recreate and
you'd be hard-pressed to come up with
someone who does it better it's all got
me super excited to see where this thing
goes next and i think that's a great
place to leave things let me know in the
comments what you thought about the
first episode in this final run how you
feel about lalo's ending and what that
means for the rest of the season please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon
you